[Musique]
kawa three bonjour merci d'être sur le
plateau de tv soixante dix huit pour ce
vip que l'on va entièrement vous
consacrez gens vous oui c'est
exceptionnel vous êtes ici pour
plusieurs raisons enfin pour une raison
vous est livrée noire vous avez habité
but que vous habitez aussi je crois
maintenant la vallée de chevreuse
voilà et vous êtes surtout l'auteur d'un
livre choc d'une bd choc c'est moi qui
dis choc qui viennent sortir qui
s'appelle cigarettes le dossier sans
filtres dont on va parler plus
longuement après avoir fait connaissance
avec vous alors jusque là tout va bien
tout va bien c'est ça le livre est sorti
jeudi le livre on dit quoi l'anc est
dessinée on n'a pas un seul d'entre eux
est dessinée financer le service est un
livre malgré tout vu d'autres voilà
c'est d'ailleurs en parlant d'image vous
êtes le scénariste et stéphane granger
est le dessinateur
bon alors ça c'est dit voilà alors vous
avez eu un début de carrière assez
original est ce qu'en font vous rêviez
d'être scénariste potter 6 a toujours
été mon but d'écrire des histoires donc
au départ je pensais plutôt des
histoires pour le cinéma ou des choses
comme ça à l'époque en fait parce que
bon j'ai pas de première jeunesse non
plus à l'époque il y avait pas de
formation de scénariste dans les écoles
de cinéma ça n'existait pas et non et
puis comme j'ai eu mon bac es à ces
jeunes voire même très jeune
je d'abord fait des études de kiné d'en
avoir mais c'était passionnant aussi
parce que c'était un centre d'intérêt
aussi et donc toute la première partie
de ma vie j'étais kiné voilà et puis le
jour où les opportunités se sont
présentées pour rencontrer des gens du
milieu de la bande dessinée ils l'ont
fait parce que je faisais j'ai sauté
dessus et puis la transition s'est faite
tranquillement sur quelques années en
fait j'ai participé à nous organiser à
dire du des premiers festivals de bd de
buc
oui c'est comme ça que j'ai rencontré
des auteurs notamment eric stalner avec
qui justin des jeux sympathisé on a
commencé à travailler ensemble sur une
série qui s'appelait la croix de cazenac
là c'est votre première oeuvre
oui c'est mon premier bouquin qui lui
même commence entre 99 et voilà le coup
de bol c'est que tout de suite le succès
a été au rendez vous et donc
progressivement pendant six ans j'ai
fait mes deux activités scénariste le
matin et qui naît de 12h à 20h
mon cabinet il ya un moment où c'était
plutôt nabeul donc en 2004 j'ai vendu
mon cabinet et je me suis lancé à corps
perdu dans l'écriture de scénarios et
depuis donc ça va bientôt faire 15 ans
tu vas aventure qu'on s'y ennuie ça
c'est formidable
donc la croix de cazenac c'était donc
qui lui disait album douze albums
voilà c'était un comme on dit à une saga
historique où c'est une saga familiale
est un petit peu fantastique sur fond de
première guerre mondiale
d'accord après vous avez aussi commis
une série qui s'appelle dantès temps
presse voilà ces pertes financières
exactement c'est
série qui a commencé en 2007 si mes
souvenirs sont bons chez dargaud aussi
il ya eu dix albums et en fait alors
inspiré oui et non c'est à dire que
c'est à peu près la même histoire que l'
affaire kerviel qu'on raconte sur ce
qu'on est sorti le tome 1 est sorti six
mois avant la sphère kerviel donc on
avait une espèce de prémonition en fait
le pitch de l'histoire c'est que notre
jérôme kerviel est un comte de monte
cristo moderne à savoir qu'il est accusé
à tort emprisonnés qui va sortir de
prison s'évader pour se venger
c'est cela oui c'est incroyable ce qui
met ça nous a fait un super buzz en fait
et la série était vraiment un gros
succès
d'accord bah écoutez super buzz c'est ce
qu'on souhaite à votre tout dernier bébé
à savoir cigarettes le dessus sans
filtre qui est là qui est sorti a très
peu de temps que sortie le 26 avril
voilà et dites moi alors ce livre est un
livre de commande de la sécurité sociale
pas vraiment en fait j'avais lu un
article sur un livre d'un universitaire
américain qui s'appelle robert proctor
le livre s'appelle golden holocauste et
l'article mettant en exergue un peu
toutes les manipulations de l'industrie
de la cigarette
donc vraiment l'arctique madame va dire
oui entre choqué et intéressé parce que
j'étais vaguement au courant de ces
questions vous avez découvert des choses
là je me disais ah bah quand même je
pensais pas que c'était à ce niveau là
ah oui et peut-être de trois jours après
je vais chez dargaud mon éditeur
principal et je discute avec le
le dg philippe ostermann qui lui venait
de se remettre à fumer
non je dis bah tiens j'ai lu un article
et il me dit mais c'est un super sujet
en fait il aurait creusé sa et donc je
me suis lancé dans la documentation
alors combien de temps va durer la
paille des préparations la préparation
une année oui romaine quasiment une
année de préparation
et puis après en fait il ya deux ans de
travail pour arriver à la sortie du
bouquin et sa réalisation et le dessin
extraordinaire de stéphane branger et a
mis tout ça en images de façon
magistrale d'accord parce que ce qu'il
faut dire c'est que tout est vrai
exactement c'est à dire je n'ai rien
inventé à part le personnage le
narrateur oui dites moi qui sais pas ce
qu'en fait oui il ya un fil conducteur à
savoir ce mr nico tu sais quoi est ce
mystère ni kobin on va dire que c'est le
mauvais génie de l'industrie de la
cigarette américaine alors est-ce qu'il
a un bon génie l'industrie les fêtes
l'industrie de la cigarette on en a on
utilise le nom de big tobacco le
désigner comme jeudi semblent dans
l'ensemble comme jeudi un surnom presque
trop affectueux pour pour des gens aussi
maléfique et donc on a imaginé cette
espèce de représentants sinico possible
de l'industrie qui va nous raconter et
embellissent figure du décor l'histoire
du tabac de la cigarette du
développement du marché et de tout ce
qui a été fait par l'industrie pour vous
et nous faire fumer surtout de la place
et si possible qui est le plus d'argent
possible tout en sachant pertinemment
qui nous empoisonnent allègrement oui
oui ils ont en fait conscience assez
rapidement
les premières alertes ont eu lieu à peu
près l'entre-deux-guerres et ce qui
s'est passé c'est que les premiers à
vraiment creuser le sujet c'était les
scientifiques nazis et parce que alors
hitler était absolument contre le fait
de fumer et les scientifiques nazis
comme vous savez ont mené de nombreuses
expériences sur la nature humaine
pas toujours très réjouissante dont donc
des expériences sur le tabac donc qu'ils
ont commencé à faire une corrélation
entre fumer et cancer du poumon puisque
c'est le cancer du poumon n'existait
quasiment pas avant l'arrivée de
cigarettes et du coup après la guerre
tout ce qu'avait fait des scientifiques
nazis étaient balayées d'un revers de
main parce que c'était des gens qui
étaient mauvais pas être utile elle été
trop méchant et donc il a fallu un petit
temps pour que la machine se remette en
route et c'est vraiment dans les uns des
années cinquante années 60 que là
vraiment les premières études ont
commencé à sortir sur la corrélation
entre maladie et tabac quelle qu elle
soit alors bon ce livre il est il des
structures et de com on peut dire de
grands chapitres on a l'impression que
vous allez prendre tous les arguments
possibles et inimaginables pour que ce
sont imparables
vous avez étudié déjà l'arrivée du tabac
après près ce cas là
au newtown d'adam et eve vous expliquer
voilà comment dire la révolution oui
voilà le tabac qui n'était pas brûlé qui
n'était pas roulé qui méprisent et chic
et qui d'ailleurs donné non pas des
cancers du poumon et le cancer du nez la
bouche de la langue à thumeries monde
déjà ça vous expliquer donc à tout le
côté historique vous expliquer que
certains il ya très très longtemps
interdisez le tabac que c'était amoral
idéal les premières les premières
facteur de lutte contre le tabac c'était
pas du tout la santé c'était vraiment
c'était vraiment un problème sociétal
c'est à dire que l'image des gens qui
fumaient étaient très mauvaises c'était
des moins que rien des plaignants qui
passaient leur temps à fumel donc ils
feraient mieux de bosser
louis s'est offert du temps voilà c'est
ça bon après ça a été
comment dire vous montrer très bien
finalement comment le tabac est
complètement intriquées impliqué dans la
vie de chacun est autant due autant que
chez par exemple le soldat à la guerre
le pauvre vieux de façon il va il va
mourir donc autour du filet des clubs
bon bref tout ça après on voit le
puritanisme américain qui commencent à
mettre le holà m'enfin ils sont
tellement puritains et pas très oui la
trouve plus le puritanisme américain a
été vraiment bien efficace parce qu au
tout début du 20e siècle il y avait des
états qui interdisait de fumer par
puritanisme uniquement mais après la
première guerre mondiale est venu là
dessus et à balayer tout ça puisqu'il ya
eu une campagne phénoménal qui a été
mise en place sur le fait que envoyer
des cigarettes aux petits gars qui se
battent et c'était bien la moindre des
choses est donc la cigarette a commencé
à être un symbole de liberté
à partir de là pour les femmes aussi et
après il ya eu entre deux guerres
l'excellent edward bernays j'ai
travaillé le frog qui travaillent et qui
a réussi à faire fumer deux femmes alors
que c'était vraiment c'était enfin les
gars allaient enfin être les égales de
l'homme commence à appliquer les
préceptes psychanalytique de son tonton
sur l'oralité de ce que voulait dire
qu'une femme n'a pu s'y arrête dans sa
bouche et il a travaillé là dessus et ça
a été ils ont juste doubler le nombre de
fumeurs voilà et idoki pratique pas ce
que vous appelez la psychologie inversée
c'est à dire sans dire non aux prêts
déjà nous ils ne fument pas tu es trop
petit et puis finalement on n'a qu'une
envie c'est de fumée pour être grande
alors ça certains surtout dans les
années 60 70
il avait des représentants qui faisait
la tournée des lycées aux états unis où
il disait vous savez vous êtes trop
jeune il faut pas fumer les fumées c'est
pour les adultes c'est comme le sexe
porter des soutiens gorge conduire tous
assez réservé aux adultes
c'est la première chose que vous et les
ados c'était de mettre à fumer puisqu'il
pensait que ce voyage c'est comme ça que
ça marche avec ses toiles à la
consommation a quand même pas mal baissé
en occident donc on s'attaque à des pays
émergents ou en voie de développement
dit on leur offre des cigarettes
paraît-il très dosé pour que parce que
la nicotine
il ya trop de choses à dire c'est une
drogue dure
oui on a plus de mal à s'en défaire que
l'héroïne ou de la cocaïne
donc déjà c'est dit
il faut savoir qu'en fait le produit que
vendent big tobacco s'est pas la
cigarette c'est pas le tabac le produit
qu'ils vendent c'est la nicotine puisque
c'est la nicotine qui crée la diction
qui va créer un besoin dans votre
cerveau et c'est ce besoin là qui va
vous pousser à fumer et donc leur seul
but c'est pas de vous cette histoire
trouve que ce soit leur seul but à eux
c'est de garder des dividendes à leurs
actionnaires
donc l'effet nicotine a toujours été
renforcée de plus en plus dans la
cigarette pour créer toujours plus de
dépendance et une fois que les gens
commencent à fumer ils sont généralement
prisonniers pour longtemps il faut
savoir qu'en france 80 % des gens qui
fument à lorient caen 16 millions de
fumeurs dont 12 millions de fumeurs
réguliers en france 80% des gens qui
fument voudrait arrêter mais n'y arrive
pas et eux leur but c'est de choquer
quand même les fumeurs le plus jeune
possible lorsque le cerveau n'est pas
complètement terminée à savoir 14 ans
une meilleur âge pour l'option n'est sûr
de la pac et qu'ils sont mais ils se
sont entraînés pour perte est presque et
je vois là un fumeur sur deux va mourir
du tabac
s'il ya des chiffres enfin il faut lire
de toute façon comme a raconté le livre
il ya le professeur yves martinet qui
fait partie du comité national de lutte
contre le tabac qui nous fait un vrai
faux qui nous exactement comme on n'a
pas des choses sur les idées reçues
voilà pour pour mettre en place tout ce
qu'on raconte nous dans le film dans le
film soit pas bien ils dansent dans le
livre par l'intermédiaire de mr nico et
d'une façon c'est vidic s'est dégonflé
le professeur martinet de cette cité ont
fait un cahier à la fin du livre
voilà avec un vrai-faux vraiment
c'est très bien à quand une version un
petit peu plus light pour les enfants et
l'herbe sous le pied oui pourquoi tabac
son pied oui voilà
et puis un argument enfin je sais pas ce
que vous allez en passer par rapport aux
jeunes maintenant qu'ils sont très très
concerné par la pollution de la planète
il faut quand même savoir que le mégot
le fils biologique total 1 déjà on
pourrait peut-être aussi appuyer les
choses s'étaient mal être au travail à
faire là dessus il ya même une toute une
fondation qui est et creuser aux états
unis qui s'appelle s'il ya la plate
forme des jeunes les américains
appellent ça les cuts cigarettes les
nigauds qui fait un très gros travail il
faut savoir par exemple que 40 % de la
pollution de la méditerranée et du est
due aux mégots qui soit étaient dans la
rue et dans les égouts pas seulement
dans la méditerranée
d'accord bon écoute et je crois qu'il
faut le lire juste c'est urgent
philibert intéressant le faire lire
aussi et puis très vite peut-être pour
une version un petit peu plus enfantine
qu'on puisse bas on vous dit en cour en
fait ça fait les cerveaux dans le bon
sens tant qu'à faire
merci pierre boisserie à très bientôt
j'ai un biotope merci
[Musique]